hey friends so my last video on toroids
reawakened an old debate that's actually
been raging for more than a decade are
anti-bent toroids actually a thing which
for the record yes they are but I also
understand the confusion they require
several leaps in logic that are not
super intuitive and today I'm here to
help Drex here from drexfactor POI
sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and in this video I want
to talk a little bit about why many
people over the years have had a hard
time wrapping their minds around
anti-bent toroids myself included but
before we dive in I want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling
pyroterra light toys spin balls and
Ultra POI for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all of these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel Lane
machinski and Becca becklinen the thank
you both so much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission
toroids represent a pretty Infamous
period in Tech POI history lots of
people don't particularly care for how
they look and the nomenclature around
them can be really confusing if not
controversial so much so that several
people over the years have suggested
that anti-benz in particular are either
poorly named or don't exist at all and
you know what they're in Good Company
because I didn't understand anti-benz at
first either back when I was first
learning toroids in 2010 I made several
videos outlining why I was baffled by
the concept and challenging the idea of
whether there could be such a thing as a
toroid that was equivalent to an
anti-spin flower and I was wrong but I
was also Lucky in that I had some
patient friends who were willing to talk
me through what I was missing and now I
want to pay it forward for all the other
Skeptics out there real quick if you
want to see more POI action please make
sure to like And subscribe so you can
see my videos as I post them thanks in
advance so housekeeping real quick what
do the terms toroid and anti-ben mean
and why are they so confusing toroids
are a subset of poi tricks centered
around plane bending in such a way that
the plane of the POI is nearly always
seen Edge on from the perspective of the
audience we describe them coming in
three varieties isobend anti-bend and
probend that correspond roughly to
extension anti-spin and in-spin flowers
in traditional 2D POI spinning and it's
here that we find one of the more common
criticisms of toroids and frankly the
first one that I raised myself see it's
easy to tell the difference between
inspin and anti-spin flowers because we
can keep the POI spinning and either
spin our hand in the same direction or
the opposite one when the POI and hand
move in the same direction we have
in-spin flowers and when they move in
opposite directions we have anti-spin
flowers but in anti-bend toroids it
seems like no matter which direction I
move my hand in the POI is spinning the
same way so how can these be considered
a counterpart to anti-spin then but
that's not the only common criticism of
antiben toroids here's another frequent
one when someone learns how to do an
anti-bend toroid there are parts of it
that don't feel terribly different from
an ISO Bend if I were to just do a
single Bend is this an anti-bend or an
ISO Bend what's really the difference
here as different as these complaints
are they actually spring from a really
similar place there's a fundamental
misunderstanding of both what the term
means as well as the movements that
they're describing and to clear things
up we're going to need to start off by
clarifying one central idea that may be
kind of hard to wrap our minds around
what if I told you the naming Convention
of toroids aren't really centered around
describing the movement of the POI
themselves
foreign
[Music]
isobend anti-bend and pro Bend are
describing has less to do with the
movement of the POI itself and more to
do with the movement of the plane that
the POI is spinning in if that sounds
like kind of a strange way to describe a
POI move that's because it is to
understand why toroids are named this
way I want to give you a little bit of
history as to where these terms came
from and I hope it'll explain what
they're actually describing and why the
convention exists in the first place so
let's turn back the clock to 2010 and a
guy by the name of Charlie Cushing now
if you're familiar with Charlie it's
likely because of his work with nine
square Theory or as the founder of prop
manufacturer Lantern Smith and it's in
ninth Square theory that Charlie tried
to fix one of the oldest problems in POI
terminology as I discussed in my video
about how we count flower petals POI
flowers kind of suffer from a lack of
precision and what the nomenclature
around them actually describes there
isn't a single falsifiable definition
for a flower petal and because of that
but there's a lot of controversy around
what constitutes a one or two petal
anti-spin flower and so Charlie sought
to clarify Matters by creating an
entirely new set of terms with clear
definitions attached to them flowers no
longer had petals they had regions where
the POI spun inside the hand path called
lobes and regions where they spun
outside the hand path called anti-lobes
and the flowers themselves why is it
that anti-spin is the opposite of
in-spin rather than say outspin for
example
Charlie instead suggested the use of
three terms to describe POI flowers ISO
spin flowers single beat flowers were
the POI and hands are locked in unison
depending on the phasing of the hand and
the POI head these result in either
extensions or isolations pro-spin
flowers that is flowers in which the POI
complete more beets than the hand and
they spin together in the same direction
this effectively was a replacement for
the term in-spin and the one term that
didn't change at all anti-spin what can
I say it just has a great Ring to it but
we would now have terms that would
directly reflect what their meaning was
in relation to each other Pro versus
anti way more intuitive than in versus
anti and if you know anything at all
about POI spinning in the past decade
you will know that this new system for
naming POI flowers did not catch on at
all but one thing it did become useful
for was naming toroids here it's helpful
to remember that the term toroid is is
actually short for toroidal flower back
in the day as we were exploring plane
bending moves that involved a circular
hand path our clearest point of
comparison was with traditional flowers
but how exactly do we go about applying
those Concepts in a context where basic
rules of timing and Direction seem to be
breaking down well Charlie and another
friend named Ted petrovsky had an idea
and it involved a little bit of
abstraction it's long been a problem in
the prop spinning world that the ways we
talk about flowers when spinning as
staff are slightly different than when
we talk about POI anti-spin is still
anti-spin and inspin is still in spin
but the shapes they each produce are
radically different depending upon the
prop
staff anti-spin flowers are very linear
and produce petals at each end of the
prop while POI anti-spin flowers are
very round and only produce petals at
the performer's thumb end so is there
any way that we can make a POI flower
more linear to match up more closely
with the appearance of a staff flower
actually there is indeed toroids most
modern POI technique is about presenting
the audience with the full profile of
the Poise movement creating round shapes
that fill up the space around us and
defaulting all POI tricks to wall plane
but what if instead we were to face the
POI plane toward the audience flattening
down the poised motion such that it
appears to be moving back and forth
along a straight line now the plane of
the POI itself becomes a more linear
object like the staff and now all of a
sudden we can think of the movement of
that POI plane as being analogous to the
movement of the staff if this is a
little challenging to visualize think of
it this way as the POI spins around in
space we're keeping track of all the
points that it moves through in its path
if we don't move our hand they wind up
looking a lot like a hula hoop a circle
hovering in space we can then turn the
hoop towards the audience so that they
see the hoop as just a straight line
rather than a circle we can then use
that line like we would a staff spinning
an in-spin or anti-spin relative to the
movement of the hand
so the terms isobend anti-bend and
probend are all describing the movement
of the POI plane as though or a staff
and this can lead to some confusion we
don't need to stall a staff in order to
switch the direction it's spinning in
and that's true of the POI plane in
toroids as well many people get confused
as to why the type of toroid doesn't
change when they switch the direction
their hand is spinning in the reason is
because they're also switching the
direction the POI plane is spinning in
too because they don't actually need to
stall the POI in order to make this
change the switch is transparent to them
and most don't even realize that they're
doing it I find it sometimes helpful to
frame things this way we have a specific
word for anti-bed that is we don't refer
to these toroids as anti-spin toroids
because we're no longer paying attention
to the direction the POI is actually
spinning in
what you bend with the POI is a plane
hence anti-bend toroids oh right and
then there's the question of whether a
single Bend is an isobend or an
anti-bend and the answer there is
well actually there isn't one here's why
I'm going to move my hand back and forth
in a straight line and let the POI spin
around it so let me ask you is this
anti-spin or in spin well the short
answer is it's neither since my hand
isn't actually following a round hand
path there's no direction of rotation to
compare the Poise movement to if I
wanted to I could expand the pattern out
to make it anti-spin or I could expand
it out to make it in spin but just by
itself there's not enough information to
say the same thing is true for toroids
if I'm just bending at the same spot as
I move my hand back and forth my hand
isn't spinning and therefore my POI
plane can't spend relative to it either
I think it's helpful to keep in mind
that the term anti-bend in itself
doesn't describe how a POI plane bends
it's an emergent property of the
movement of the hand as it swings
through space and how the POI plane
spins relative to that as a point of
comparison if I just spun my POI and
asked if it was an anti spin or an
inspin the question comes off as
nonsensical anti-spin is an adjective
describing a flower not a noun anti-bed
works the same way so to summarize
anti-bend is a real thing despite what
directs from a decade ago and what many
other people have believed over the
years and it's definitely a bit
confusing because it requires quite a
lot of abstraction and visualization of
the POI and the POI plane's movements to
say nothing of borrowing ideas from
other props to complete this picture and
the naming convention is based in an
obscure attempt to overhaul the terms
around POI flowers because that naming
convention never really took off it also
means that what should have been an
intuitive leap from one type of flower
to another now has an unintentional
linguistic barrier between them but
through it all toroids are still super
cool and antiben toroids especially so I
really appreciate Charlie and Teddy for
coming up with a way to classify a type
of poi tricks that most of us were
struggling to wrap our heads around and
for being very patient with me is I
struggle to understand what those terms
really meant hopefully I have honored
both of their time by teaching others
what they taught me did this video help
to clear things up for you on anti-bent
toroids please leave me a comment and
let me know if you have any additional
questions next month I'll also be
dropping my long-awaited video on probin
toroids so keep an eye out if you got
anything out of this video please make
sure to like comment share and subscribe
to help other people find it to keep the
conversation going and to help my
channel grow
this video would not be possible without
the kind support of all of these awesome
people right here these are my flow
patrons and they along with the padawans
listed down in the description make my
channel and all my videos possible by
supporting my work on patreon thank you
one and all for your very generous
support if you dig my content and want
to see me make more of it please
consider signing up to support my work
over at patreon.com
drexfactorpoi you can follow the link
down in the description of this video or
the card that just popped up if you're
watching on YouTube there you can get
access to my videos the day before the
rest of the world bite-sized weekly
lessons that get delivered straight to
your email inbox and a whole host of
other awesome rewards and even better
you'll be helping me spread the love of
flow Arts far and wide do give it a look
please and thank you if you'd like to
learn more about POI toroids I've got a
playlist of videos I've done on the
topic link to down in the description as
well as up here on screen if you'd like
to check them out also the YouTube
algorithm thinks that you might like
this topic video here based upon your
past viewing habits so maybe give that a
look as well thanks so much for watching
make sure to get outside and flow today
and I'll see you with a new video real
soon
peace